so what happens when legal eagle gets
called for jury duty yeah that's right
your boy got jury duty yes you probably
hate it but I'm actually looking forward
to it this is the mtry courthouse in
Washington DC I practiced here many many
times I've never served on a jury here
so this could be fun who knows yes I'm
wearing a suit and no I'm not wearing a
tie because I want to show respect for
the court but also I'm not getting paid
for this and it's kind of cold out today
sadly it's all over I was all you can't
handle the truth and they're like you're
excused Mr Stone uh no actually I went
into the jury lounge and then after
waiting for about uh I don't know 15 or
20 minutes they said there were no more
trials to call for jury service today so
sadly I will not need to be called for
two more years which I'm really I'm sad
about I was really hoping to you know be
on the other side of the process of of
trial law but you know that's the way it
goes if you need a great lawyer for
non-jury Duty reasons check out Eagle
team get a free consultation today Link
in the bio and comments